bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors sur quoi reposent
ces nouvelles accusations contre le
géant chinois
bonjour c'est assez complexe parce qu'il
ya aujourd'hui 16 chefs d'accusation
alors qu'elle avait déjà 13 dans
l'accusation précédente ya j'allais lire
deux éléments qui sont importants
premiers éléments les nouveaux chefs
d'accusation inclut la question de la
corée du nord là on est un peu dans le
même cas que dans le que que dans le cas
des actions supposer leur huawei au
niveau de l'iran on est dans le cas de
ces lois d'exception
d'extraterritorialité américaine qui
sont j'allais dire au delà du fonds le
fonds appartient là il appartient à la
justice de le trancher sur le principe
ce sont des lois dont il faut rappeler
qu elles sont contestées par une partie
du monde
et puis ou l'autre parent ce qui est
très intéressant très intriguant c'est
qu'en fait l'accusation porte
aujourd'hui sur un une loi différente
nouvel acte d'accusation ne porte plus
sur une succession de loin qui auraient
été enfreintes mais sur un acte c'est à
dire une législation américaine très
particulière qui leur actif le colloque
organisation si je traduis l'accusation
c'est plus généralement et plus
génériquement de considérer que le roi
est une organisation criminelle qui
aurait fait du racket de l'influencé de
la corruption
donc on a passé une étape n'est pas
simplement on n'a pas simplement rajouté
trois chefs d'accusation on a passé une
étape qui est extrêmement importante
mais qui est très étonnante parce que
cet acte qui date de 1970 a été utilisée
j'aime venir 1 90% contre des
organisations criminelles des mafias
alors des mafias de fleury de chicago et
c'est un véritable mafia ou contre des
j'admire des hommes politiques corrompus
aux etats unis c'est la première fois
que cet acte est utilisé contre une
entreprise étrangère ça ça pose question
mais derrière tous ces accusations est
ce qu'en réalité ce qui se cache
finalement c'est les ambitions de
déploiement de la 5g de la parade oui
oui je crois qu'il faut être prudent
parce que si vous voulez c'est un
secteur particulier d'un secteur
particulier à plusieurs titres d'abord
c'est vrai que dans différents pays et
je dirais même dans l'ensemble des pays
etats unis compris europe comprise les
services spéciaux des pays concernés ont
sont en discussion nécessairement avec
leurs entreprises nationales ça n'a rien
de propre à la chine 3 wedding pas le
faire mais les entreprises françaises le
fonds allemande le font les entreprises
américaines le fond on est quand même
dans un domaine très particulier de
sécurité de défense
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'on est dans
un domaine nécessairement ch j'allais
dire d'espionnage mais c'est vrai qu'un
secteur qui est très parc premier tour
deuxième point qui rend ce secteur très
particulier c'est que comme tous les
secteurs industriels la propriété
industrielle est une combinaison très
complexe très nombreuses de savoir-faire
très nombreux très disséminée y compris
des savoir faire qui sont niés avons et
qui sont dans les dépositaires sont vos
fournisseurs donc chaque contrat avec un
fournisseur dans cette industrie et est
assorti de tout un tas de clause de non
partagée c'est très complexe à suivre à
démontrer et un très grand travail de
ces entreprises de l'ensemble des
entreprises qu'elles soient chinois zhu
par consiste d'une part à développer le
savoir-faire et de la propriété
intellectuelle de l'autre par la
protéger et cibler ces deux travaux sont
aussi importants je voulais simplement
dire c'est un peu complexe mais c'est
important de comprendre ça donc tous
ça donne ça répond à votre question sur
le fait que pour démontrer ce genre
d'accusations ça prend un temps une
masse de données masse danalyse qui est
extrêmement importante sur temps ce
temps peut être mise à profit pour
mettre en place de la concurrence et
empêché le déploiement d'un pays d'un
d'une entreprise dans un pays
merci beaucoup je regrette c'est d'avoir
été avec nous merci pour cette analyse
je rappelle que vous êtes économiste crs
et président de tient tant que the
bridge temps merci à vous